well I'm penny wise can sue Clow
lady wise yes those of you who have seen
the latest adaptation of Stephen King's
it may be forgiven for thinking that
penny wise is just a terrifying clown
the film does spend a small amount of
time making it clear that penny wise or
it as it's commonly referred to by the
children of Derry is not just a clown
but what exactly is penny wise if we
take a look at Kings novel or even the
1990 miniseries penny wise is described
as been an ancient cosmic being the
novel even refers to him as a devourer
of worlds who can take many different
forms we can compare penny wise to a
Bobbitt in JK Rowling's Harry Potter as
it can transform into whatever you fear
most it is made very clear it
particularly enjoys feeding on young
children as they are easier to scare and
it seems fear enhances the flavour of
his prey he even goes as far as to claim
the exotic terrors and fears of human
beings make their flesh taste better
comparing the process of inducing fear
to salt in the meat Pennywise the clown
is not the monsters true form it is just
a mesh shape that it has assumed it has
no gender and it comes from a
surrounding universe known as the macro
verse we as humans cannot comprehend its
true form the closest we come is that of
a giant spider that looks to be inspired
by the work of HP Lovecraft it is made
from an energy known as the dead lights
that originates in the macro verse the
dead lights appear as spectral orange
lights and the book mentions that the
mere sight of the dead lights is enough
to kill a person
in the movie we see it using the dead
lights as a weapon against the people of
Derry when attempting to consume them as
the creature appears to be a celestial
being it cannot be killed through
conventional means the only way to kill
it is through the ritual of chewed it
awakens from its hibernation every 27 to
30 years to feed on the flesh of
innocent children the awakening is
always marked by a brutal act of
violence as the creature is drawn to
suffering and tragedy with it being a
supernatural entity it has a host of
special powers and abilities including
shape-shifting teleportation
regeneration and even the ability to
create illusions its greatest enemy is a
giant god-like turtle named Mattern who
inhabits the Mac reverse the two are
locked in an internal and symbolic
battle I guess we have to give credit to
Stephen King here because he's created a
universe where a child murdering clown
is enemies of a giant turtle from outer
space the reason that it is so
terrifying is the fact that it has no
appearance it can adapt and become
whatever you fear most
if you've enjoyed this video then please
consider leaving a thumbs up as it helps
promote the video and allows the channel
to grow if there's anything you'd like
to discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please let me know in the
comment section as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained